okay so this section will be over Skype
what could possibly go wrong
Chang Liu is joining us from Shanghai us
TC unfortunately couldn't get his visa
didn't arrive on time he'll be talking
about quantum supremacy or as it's
called in the States
alt quantum and the title of his talk is
towards demonstrating quantum supremacy
by creating perfect single photon
sources okay thank you young and first I
would like to thank the committee for
give me this good opportunity and also
focus for allow me to present my truck
by remote radio Terry conference and and
also many thanks to the organizers for
taking a lot of tablets to setting up
this very nice video conference which I
it's the best quality I have used in
video conference so today I will talk
about our recent experimental research
on optical quantum computation or to use
another fancy title beating you know our
computing quantum boson assembly
machines and so what I would like to
thank my collaborators including Japan
he is the director of the content
Research Center here in Shanghai in the
author interfaith of our University and
also I would like to thank from the
University of usable in Germany for
providing us high 48
for examples and
so and also education and so at least I
was a fortress father to be useful for
the fondant applications as I just
mentioned you know a shopping list is in
addition to the transportation for
example the photon can be characterized
by frequency
momentum but for the condom patients
either sound more list so you need to be
single photons and also it needs high in
distinction to DT I will also briefly
use fixed planes so imagine we have
three black box each imaging a string of
photons raised identical in all the
classical degree students at the
frequency position as I just mentioned
so how to distinguish sleep sleep box so
we have kind of feeling that there's a
table align the photons you know they
don't like just feel help to keep the
distance and the bottom line the photos
they like to punch each other like we
did in public so to calculate this
statistic behavior we can use the second
all collision which is a correlation
between intensity of view and measure
the second for the foundation using
with just soup split in I mean photon
field i 15 speech analyzed and we can
now we can see that for three photos we
will have different behaviors the middle
line which is alert will be part black
which is the most common is the laser
and it's the double line the deeper end
attention here's a do not handle a you
know she'll never the case that i
finished and this is really nice
behavior of the light of you that it we
have to finish in the field that either
go this way or that way
and so the single bottoms
it's sufficient in many occasions like
for example an execution performed on
metal and aluminum duty
we also need a sound wave or full single
boat house to talk or interact with each
other but uniform have very weak
interactions which is abundant in
long-distance communication but for
funnin computing is a disadvantage but
in 1987 he will stop the way for two
photos to have some kind of interaction
mechanic this is when the two verbs are
surely identical for the mechanically
essential and it was a super impose
50/50 speed you know there will be the
two photon will always exceed single
forum interposed EC or bottom both de
and this is part because of the pencil a
she comes to terms and alloys only when
Julie identical so by this you know that
seemed to have some you know interaction
of many occasions in photon logic
control logic age so as I have mentioned
the photon starts a plastic line meets
very small decoherence in in free space
so it has already you know for the
foreign communications became already we
can in China we have launched on a
science experiments and also by the end
of
last year we have now filled with Putin
Babylon page into Shanghai which is
southern kilometers by eating trustful
Bay and actually it had handy the launch
of the satellite we have managed to get
you have established satellite to blood
connection you can see this is a picture
you can taken directly use yo yo yo
yourself and these are the patient
lasers
the latter one is from the bomb station
and as a satellite and you see
estimations for the funding science
project on an satellite project so the
first one is to treat is to step two is
the at Boise State Constitution from one
station station and then used satellite
holiday to establish phone and sheet in
him long and the Nansen which is
separated by most 2000 kilometres and
the second is to use and is accepted by
all the fun insulting 200 kilometers and
the use intended for us to test first
inequality in the thousand kilometers
field and the third mission is to do fun
and station and well so please keep and
I think south
announced fallacy so face always
progressed maybe we can envision invent
in the future
so the talk I will mainly so my products
they will mainly focus on the more
challenge in fact beauty you know we now
know that at phone communications will
be no later for less have some
applications beauties you know that has
been there for a long time and is units
Edwards for the impacts of Google and
also in 2015 also establish a joint the
board which is the largest in China so
the question you want to ask is when do
science loss and besides repeat actual
machine we can put on desk - you know
which is practically useful so for
photos I will just briefly summarize
history so before 2001 you know we have
yes that formal communication using
photon will be possible
you know laughing and maybe who want to
prove that proposal that in your body
beauty is in principle for and the slew
the development of the first stage and
million gates
by these guys the resource required to
achieve one nice Enoch has been greatly
reduced over the years five so if we
brought the resource needed for in our
gate as a function of the year at the
financial side and as an experiment
issed we have been very quickly you know
expect it was a continuous em in a year
allah saving only lesson
you know didn't happen on the other side
experiments has been going much slower
than have been have been affecting those
fleeing the bleeding perdida point is is
of
Phoebe's argument is through parametric
down-conversion
in where we use actual valid you feel is
to company pistol and as he is the tiny
minus nine and that will find you people
into these two points or you see in
light source and argument and
you know and also now we can so we
should first beautify our unit for the
fauna which probably maybe does not need
portfolios and we can understand
deployment of millions of bees can be
reduced to tens of physical hippies and
one such task for or photons photons MP
photo sampling is the classical analog
of water board you know if you jump
first o first through this network you
can expect the Gaussian distribution
is it will place the purpose by quantum
mechanically indistinguishable and we
will be sent photons Lucy's talk we will
expect very different distribution that
to calculate or predict the art
using of the so it has been and the
challenge that beating us so basically
put on some brain food consists of the
three component boring single photo
sauce the second one is leaning of the
six of eight
and this sleep path in in many cases can
be difficult
so what are limiting us is the three
component and probably the most
significant challenge is open up sauce
and the problem we soju wish the don't
convert over the years you know why is
the body photo in Hungary mustard you
know the thermal photons we can eat
Hangul over the years increased very
slowly being it financially is because
that the process create one intangible
yes or when the photon is probabilistic
so for example for two bottles for the
baby
P three four six four three and the
piece typically never smoking or press
the high or advance
so is it which is very slowly
and the different ways to create this it
mean anything is a monistic thing for a
source one way is to convert the
herbalist spdc into deterministic by
using using motive tactic of many source
also you know the field has you know
this tank has been developed adding more
than 15 years were still you know the
performance is very limited so we said
why we now switch to single phone
emitters that naturally and and give us
one and only one photon each time and if
there are many candidates single three
meters for example and using intuitive
price mutual items but if you visit the
labs overhead of experiment is usually
very
you know it was whose atoms and also
easy very sophisticated electronics to
those an optical houses panacea also
sorry state are a few agents for example
Donovan Alexander's and the fun for many
color centers publicly is that the
efficiency of the imputation is not high
all theists or the uniform line is only
the immediate spectrum for example for
Andy's enters the Aleppo no light
consists of filming sleep center of the
ball emission and only the szayelaporro
night can be made you know indistinct
full food for corridor advantage is that
for me efficiency is new unity about 98%
so but a typical problem of the sorest
assistance it's usually more noisy
all right so can we combine the very
high point of the you know phone
eventually Naturalizer and at which the
solid state that so I will first explain
how II and how he prepares samples so
the Indian as an ID on an awesome
self assembly using molecule in twenty
six molar layer of in last night and the
because of the lattice constant
mismatch in denial on small penny
meat-filled jobs is a can imagine I
which the height is only about 400
nanometers and it is to make fine and
discrete levels so the Condor here
the final feud you know people have
demonstrate Singapore emission by otani
fan she means 2000 in the year of 2005
shuttle Endeavour but all these
experiments you know a single photon
emitted you're prepared for the phone
bill experiment cannot actually the
Louisan is that useful for the singapore
a sauce has to fulfill a very demanding
catalyst with five with five criteria
and at least five list has to be
fulfilled in mutiny it's not a separate
so the first one is to have - efficient
energy in and predominately determinist
by le Sacre long is determine each
generation so using a fast station
so the sauce should image a push in the
photo song and the third one is the
photos feature you know only single
contribution but contribution those a
pseudo force is it is to have high
english english suitability as as i have
plain
follow Mendeley the feelers and the song
is should have high efficiency you know
he'll be back in in the mode is high
efficient those are so the first problem
between to solve is i unity because
previously the photon emitted it is only
up to 70 percent
you know you actually fly in Athenian
state and for - so when the time limit
and also in this technique typically we
need to use very shy Apollo patient and
physically oxygen and so will you know
why we'll cause sexual wonder ease of
immediate food and although so the
photons will be people you know they
can't think she went by energy so true
so probably we prefer Shakti which is
fast retinal averted
so we expire the fun dog purely then
simply using this special occasion later
and this is a pivotal section we have
default the sake meters the valley floor
fat loss or the leader for the leader
leakage it is log and the valley shop
fish is on a mission we can we use all
riders who you think the laser
background because the animation is
circulate for life and so we expect near
for me we can finish the laser back on
using for light each sleep for lighting
a politician so Emily change the laser
field as a laser intensity we can see a
very nice Fabio solution and we we can
handle chemistry using continuously
getting he tabulated and the increase
the see a belated father we can see
solution for storing social life or a
chip rate so these two are equivalent
radius of the full Apple Asian
population in the molecule age you know
when was the Rabi frequency gets larger
and it's larger sense like snorting
spontaneous emission rate of the food
food Super sisters the global solution
will modulate the forming animation and
so we can continue today which is about
to an oak and the deeper a teacher
monistic generation Singapore in a
push-button manner so fast well recently
the conduct the Canada morning Tony
although and you can see for this so did
a fine it was you know these lot in
point is already a phallic scenes and we
started moving so did that give a very
opportunistic picking up said as a solid
state and if you just hand you know if
if you do it properly and can be seen as
surprised at a fashion so the milk means
money motivation gave that with this new
station model and we have higher foreign
policy so we use two volunteers
visibility immediate photon and for the
first time exempted that the previous
image of seventy cents a piece of ham
and the fifth contemptuously the
bleeding and the later one year later
comment we can consider that indeed
sincerity
so now we transfer the chocolate and the
invincible using fast and battle bishop
support employee handbook in unity with
a unity indistinct three so one
remaining problem is the fact and
efficiency of the jingle so as we have
seen that so is alejandra the forums
already led it's beautifully mystically
but but because the magics of the phone
dog is very much tied back in there
so we bought any cavalry started the
phone the faction about 17 degrees so we
thought annex have a structure is only a
17-3 so it's the soil and do photo
actually emit may actually exceed for
the material and that will have that
response to the actual mission
extraction efficiency from the bar to to
put them although the forums are a
generation with high vision cannot
actually collect so naturally soft and
on this figure you can see little
trouble well the best 58 thermal feature
using thankful personification with
every structure you can see the power
near saturation to excite the fun in
solution is from the photo of a few
hundred
I hope I get motivation and all another
big popular is for the latest project
values and teach or increase about the
FN extent
so it's also inviting if using naturally
include each feature it's a trade-off
between sufficient input of purity and
so we need to find a way that we can
happily compatible a half-height for
suction and a meanwhile you know
maintain a very high quality so early
last year we now have stable all these
other five sadly some so the phone or
device we replicated the trainee as you
can see here and here's the happy in
scapula which is four five fifteen see
if any file can be appended which has
two and we found out into the two point
five five for Danny's mussel Phyllis and
these phones the very typical single
action inside a box problem which a
numeric numerically stimuli the line
field inside the peeler and also
powerful photo and and because of this
originally problem like you so we can
see the degree of the so when the
founder and the cavity is resonant the
lifetime of pool app system is decreased
from 606 m less than then we can smell
the peach using post resonant excitation
and so the Peters body oscillation is so
so in this paper
the fridge we have reported a single
photon counting front of 3.7 million
Singapore Sun second which is what we
eventually saw those are actual for us
out of a single mode fiber is about 27
people per second and who listened
anyway we can put optimized optical
element and now eventually octopus on a
silicon detector we can see nine made in
Singapore second which is the so the
left reach peak is about 76 method so it
is the brightest as Singapore sauce in
all this but we can say speech in the
film it to have security in the photo
you can see that the deal with handle a
CSS and one set contribution of oh who
bought her event
so the Qt better than 30 died and also
for for mental experiments with the
trance of illusion of two nanoseconds
deep you know when the supporters are
prepared we also know for a vision
diversion of this conference because we
on purpose we make the fur industry
extinction and the wonderful for us when
the afar region is terrible you can
express significant refresh and we had
extract the photo pink fijian 1985 so
all these features you know the fog
impurity in the agency is very nicely
and exciting and in this part we can see
that
celebration the food photo it's only for
humanity and in a late experiment that
we can beat them with was a increase
that trance evolution from no second
chance of my project and we can see that
for stream of more than 1000
he can still maintain photon disability
over 92% so logical you can see that
what is the kind of of the decrease of
four minutes before 96 10:22 p.m. which
occurs at a time scale of 1 micro second
so he didn't time skill of the
decoherence environment that conduct
experience is a micropenis which is
mainly induced by a vacuum fluctuations
happens in a microsecond so for two
burners deities that emitted with
evolution much smaller than try to
separate you know the food water is sort
of like dictating which state he will
experience the theme fluctuation so in
dictionary is it's higher and the second
thing we get is that even in the valley
lon thank you you know the photo is 22%
petal so it indicates that the
decoherence of a gradually filled
partition is small compared to the
intrinsic language
so you can see vlog itself better for up
the borders we can have photo files over
9000 in principle up to 1000 the photon
unit of 40 is probably no longer open so
if this we are fighting ready for body
for experiments with conduct so what we
do that is we can have any dependent you
know the assembly found on each people
they have given with landscape enemy so
well polished to engineer many
independent under basement you know
more efficient and more comical we
actually in order any vision so imagine
we have incoming Singapore the past in
you know safley by second Austin you can
send using a cocktail or electrical
optical modulator to surface to actively
be both have a more effective in two
different vigil it one prepare fight you
know independent of a thought experiment
early you can you know for yourself that
have high vision with either Fagin
accent despot time is the only mention
so in the actual plan we can prove any
photo
and and you see the there will be more
fat
for example Singapore Austrian five in
Japan in and the tool performed modern
families be another important in making
sex which is a symbol of people in the
field so previously were secret people
mainly use with a face tonic sick body
mode in the Philippines the dimension
six and the most significant challenge
is that the efficiency of this wing of
the metal is quite low from about 10
percent to 75 paise so these
efficiencies were also feels essentially
and which efficiency so we want to have
a new design of such a low loss body in
the first thing about what is most
essential for high efficiency photon son
and that is you know the most important
features is that the melody to the peace
table to the high you have high
transmission page and the implement a
London uniquely magic and if you know is
a very essential for high performance
and polish is viable for the top is
essential sadly the other one is very
small
tunable so harshly you know the previous
design limited efficient transmission
rate so now we forward it to to do
design in the Philippines which have
which total the left on its time I spy
fifteen and visa for a bra so actually
how do you design products before the
restart long individual individual few
silicon played the very finest polished
and atrophied or lie TV speaking visuals
and because you know we hope we can
achieve verify transmission rate so the
99th with my mind are usually before
nine and then we can buy it in molecule
fusing together and he did coding you
know we can typically different layers
and also is it dependent on the incoming
over polarization so we have sand flea
of nobility and so in the philometor
is equivalent to these triangular sleep
in a field and also because when we
family to me the face is essential and
the usually is after London its London
and the one typical in the film the test
in Chiba London magic so the feature of
this in the film it is that it has a
very high transmission rate also have
verified symbol over
so that of all of each of families like
this with one conduct Umatilla immediate
high performance Singapore a sauce amor
amor attractions with even a stereo mode
and the census is modular loss chronic
cookie and the detected by clickin be it
in this experiment we have combined for
connoisseurs and the lowest lost of
people Sookie are the detection is only
30% efficiency silicon so now we can
achieve three four and a five photon for
the family the 3 portable assembly is
about 5 more than 5 the magnitude
fastest and all the 3d system taking
advantage
our highest performance in apple sauce
and although the a shallow loss optical
circuit and also in a field experiment
using down conversion only chemistry
people for something fun and interesting
we can also you know compare performance
fairly flimsy food assembly machine but
it will eat executed any of Terry and
family other family machine and eat
voluntary - I used to carry per minute
so for people very optimistic about
chronic duty you know we can because we
shall show that at the very heart
exactly on in computing candidate in the
photo
you know how can you spell it
oh oh you know all the need for the
parcel and tell him to me and baby
so successful last slide like kill you
poodles what people
yeah right that and so we that
are there any questions for Xianyang
don't
of course single photon sources have a
lot of other applications as you as you
discussed but what do you see in looking
forward in the longer term for the
prospects of integrating large number of
components together I mean right now
there are there's competition between
different technologies for achieving
quantum computation do you think that in
the running with
anything in fact I think that the valley
ecology the the war we both here if you
want to
okay we don't yet it's great for larger
the possible to use a machine it's
probably you know on the skills of
people that is a kind woman
and even a lot of future with hope in
the
okay we're having a bit of trouble with
the video and the audio um we could try
more questions if there are
okay um Krista is gonna make some
announcements but before she does it
let's thank our speaker again
[Applause]